This is karen so perky interviewing rain apparently in this mall on the fifth of ninety ninety three take to reno tell
me about some of the school stories. Can you remember anything particular about going to school.
My only thing that sticks most me in my mind is when we went to my brother and i are going to do you guys school.
My parents couldn't speak english so obviously they wouldn't take us to school and that was you know old really.
And my brother had too much work to do everyone had so much work to do that we had to go on our own. So.
From right up on top. What was called gun alley. We went down to and you go our school.
We went to the school ran and stood there apart because nobody knew us.
When the bell rang to go in we marched in with the other kids but seeing that we had that we had to see it.
We just told in print of the class. When they everyone was so good.
The teacher turned towards this is not him was mr mcnaught. And he said. Why are you here.
And my brother who was older than i but he was a bit more timid myself. He didn't say anything.
So i said because my mother seen me. So then he needs say this but it wasn't a very good introduction to school.
But i rather large school so i got on all right. But he was the only one that gave me that kind.
And even to this guy but i got because i met him and what i'm going to call.
What did you get it for where we were reading outside..
When we were sitting in stools then he told us we were to read the post. Paragraph h. And i love reading especially.
And the girl next to me. Just kept on and on and on and she wouldn't sit down.
So i got a boy that got him by the grace and gave her a tag.
And i don't know if she stumbled or what but anyway the two just saw me and he gave me two cats
and they came up in blisters on me and i just think god did it for matt. Maybe he had other ideas.
But he had written here i might add that i'm not ready to stop of our modern mind of blue.
But what kind of lunches did you take to school. I don't talk to me but having lunch is carrying.
We have to have home my bread. And i hide it.
Everybody had this noise square on board bridge and we had home mine braided in the summer it was really delicious.
You could smell it you know cooking in the window wasn't so successful. But mum. Mother or. My sister used to do it.
She used to maggot sort of in a long bun. And that wasn't square. I want to square braid.
And on top of that i had to help my god what they do would be to get the yeast. And in the beginning.
By somehow my the yeast and of the stomach of cups or something on them and i can't even tell you.
There might be other people that can tell you that as you go along.
That we may see my night in with the years we used about a flare in they would be in their hundred pound bags i think
that like a corn bag. And it said it sorry. Was it program can you think. The now.
Well not so much for us because we did use a lot. Sort of thing not that i can remember. Anyway.
And then that's to say it and then of course it had to be needed.
So that devised a contraption which was a bad it would create or two and a half foot square board.
And then on that it had a stick a text. With some about sidney and.
And i was the one that had to go up and they are up and down with the stick while the others to break into it and.
So that's the story about brave and i just didn't complete all have or for a wife felt that brave.
And if we were a man. Sometimes rename it up.
And this is trying because i mean it's just a reminder though i mean the other day.
My eldest sister would make patty cakes. So it was a the high and my great aunt patty cakes. How many lies.
How many lies. Would you like you know the section of fish and. Well i really don't remember but.
We used to my community every day. So it was always fresh bread.
And now i mean you know fresh green bean thing wouldn't mind what would you take with it just has to be changed so
jamie i think. And i think within the americas article didn't know about payment but when jim martin was dies.
I suppose it was around that we didn't our bit of it
and another thing i remember from that same school was that in war time not me jumping ahead a bit
but it doesn't matter. During the war. This was to go screw you go to school i want to be a man. And you know.
Close on to fourteen men and destroy a sea of me saying. Italians destroy him. Abort the romance. Only and.
Everyone was so happy that the teacher gave us a half day holiday. So i went and i said. Have come yet.
And i said we're going to have to i hope one day because the save me saying abort me. Where you should have seen it.
I said don't you know that that's an italian ship. And they were all italians on that. And i have.
Countrymen what sank. I didn't i was a tell you know i was just a kid. That must have been a bit confusing. The child.
Well it was going to sing you know why that. L.r.
Didn't change at all because my brother was naturalized therefore we had a radio all the time. And he had a gun.
Which i'm naturalized. People had to put the scene. And they also had to give a radio.
But we had this big i think they used to call him a jewish. Radio. It was a big.
Contraption anyway about two and a half feet wide but three feet high.
And we would be able to catch the transmissions from either scenes.
So i was found out and remember there are always trying to listen to news from italy.
I don't have a favorite heard in me. So if you know if they will send it.
Naturalized was it illegal for him to have it right here yes they would have taken it off. Me a bit.
In the tour this is during the war you know his heart was a bit. Fourteen years.
Was there any danger enough that the many of your family. Be taken prisoner of war during the eyes. Yes.
Well i suppose there was always the danger that a man of our family when my father was rather elderly and.
But i would have to have some evidence that had. I have been the fastest. Paddy in the family.
Which none of us when my brother lived through it when he was i mean there was no way. He could have been.
But just sign. I just like to say here that. The feelings for the mum elaine was too strong. At that time.
And you can understand more that would you want to listen to news.
And even people that knew that we had the radio that asked did you hear in him you. You know.
This was one thing that they're striking and sort of found hand hard to understand.
But if you think that if you had been a strange country and. Couldn't speak the language.
It would have been nice to hear. Your own time. But of course it was war and.
There was no you didn't hear your parents be talking about anyone else.
Being taken this reason or formerly were others that are just.
That probably need but i just forget the ny times now and. Maybe sort of.
That wouldn't want to be putting in the why the good guy remember one one time. Just to tell you sort of help.
Things were. This is going back a while when i was a bad team my mother was very sick. She had to go to hospital.
She had three operations in the one that.
And everyone thought that she wouldn't like it that was the feeling that we had at home.
But i didn't go on to say it because i didn't have a decent for up to put on. And being poor but prayer.
And especially my mother was a very proud woman. But she wouldn't want to probably see me if i wasn't dressed properly.
But anyway the decision was made that i didn't get on so you know. She didn't like it by the way i moved to.
Not to be nobody to know what was wrong with no one was a gold star and. One was the appendix.
And the other one her stomach and for.
Dr mccoy i performed the operation she had been to doctors in sydney and all over the place because she was so sick.
And the family had what was wrong and she made it and was pretty healthy after that we would say from.
Doctor and i don't know what it was used to have officers on the corner room. And now as we're straight i think.
So he was in this mall. He was in recent years years he was a little more doctor not a very old doctor.
Maybe it was it would have been either you know something about him and. I remember getting mean to say my mother.
Unlike a later time when she had a bad child. And she said she said.
Get me up at three o'clock in the morning you see certain washing machine that i can get warm again
and she said i'm just freezing cold or do you think i can do anything about it.
So i might have my business to be there when dr mccoy. And i said to him dr i said mom said. So and such.
And he turned to the nurse and said. Why do you wash her at that time. And she said our doctor she says that's.
Routine we wash patients and that time and he said labor dirty then. And after that she was washed in the daytime.
The session.
Would have been in the original base hospital
and she was in karen dinner i think at the time was news that was carried on the net
and there were also were we hospital where with i situated are you asking me too much now carry a martyr and.
As a matter of fact i tried to get past where i thought the current you know was
and i couldn't find that there was also the damn griles. Which was originally the ira social club.
Because your mother in there was one hospital.
But i can remember going to reno what was it like being the youngest of such a large family. Well i didn't.
I wasn't spoiled.
If that's what you're trying to get up here in but i certainly wasn't it wasn't just it wasn't much for anybody. So.
Nothing nothing new you know really even just. Sometimes i reckon that i just grew up watching what would happen.
Because there just wasn't home and i was sick when i was young and very sick
and being the youngest didn't get you out of during any chores now and then i might. With the one that did that.
He's since passed away he was killed in an accident in sydney in the net. Now.
It was the money i could get away with anything i was too.
Statman so i mean i didn't have a crawling body me but i mean. So i'm used to always get into trouble.
Do you know it's but it was very nice decided it was affecting you and i do you remember much about your sister.
I know you don't mean into the bad here but you know i'm not sure that you sister the now.
And i mean that very well that was told to me she died when she was twenty i'd stay in the convent.
What part of the highway where was she i think she was.
When to write a match to she went into the convent she would be no debate today at seventeen you know.
And then my mother had a big fight a grandfather and. She got in last night around.
But then she really never entered into my life and prayed when did you make your husband run in a few days.
To rejigger i remained for the game but i mean for me because i had to be sharp right
and then my brother were going out of being a kind of the outward rather than being the g.
Guy and i think i may be way better than your memories you know that i'm probably one of the many
when i'm not a young child or there are a few young marines around.
And i remember my sister and i think you know i mean you know you had to write a lot of anybody say about a guy
and really just. I'm not happy about him coming i'm doing the right thing and even when i'm out of it.
Let them not fight it went on man. We're going to be out here again.
And really you know it would mean if you need to write a letter to me no matter when he was nineteen years old
when you when you met your husband. And when i met him i was probably that sixteen.
Man a man we thought a guy thinking of them when i was seventeen.
Did you write and write years you couldn't go anywhere you not and i had with him that night
and we're going to marry my dream may be greater than the brother. Come to that and.
And i think i think you know i'm not going to think that's a.
I'm not going to but dad
and i really want to quoting the benefit of a nice five hundred eighteen i mean i mean they only draw a minimum
and that it's great to have a maid and everything that happened.
I think you bring a map to be in the front room on your way as you wrote on that
or even history that you could run around the meat that you need and you didn't have any into the family farm
and you know just great and it didn't matter that. But i mean you know that the getting found that a room.
Were ripe for the young woman running into a young girl bragging to rome and going to read it from my padded. Radnor.
And i think. I mean. We didn't get any way we didn't do anything but write any young people and i did a little around.
Where we knew. My sister got married.
Or we you know that and i dated five of them me when they met you know i did have a family. Driving on the brain.
But we didn't have any makes me not you know. And a matter of fact i remember one time i did not have a.
Sort of the brain that we used to buy i had graduated marang and.
And she had asked me to go to the shire with and we made at the shop at a foundry. That i feel kind of right to have.
I don't know that to me that i had to get rid of when my mother sister
and i looked at her going to know that any right. It was the only lightly.
For the rope and a great deal of weight and for that matter wouldn't a great deal of freedom and it was not one.
Would be in had the thing to do you that you could know that i love raining i still love.
Raining here with your five little. I don't have any private over that i grew up and i'm sure that story a good thing.
My brothers left storybooks but they used to hide under the mattress and anyway.
And i'll get a table of the right amount that i didn't find and sad at the thought that i made actually here.
Except from school the tank books from the library. Rain that. You mentioned something about a band.
I deny that kind of night out after we were married.
About five it probably mattered if you know any amount if i got a bad night. For me there.
And i thought we were married and you have to ask me about me waiting on you and i can act and.
Married we want to leave the door when you can. And not have been and about that and i had planted bananas.
And i got a laced with.
Everyone had to do that and that man and i got the lace to run up to five years with a ten year option.
I mean the main time we got married and. Five years wrap redeemed and the lawyer said.
He met that wanted to get the option on it or not attain it.
And i learned how to limit the end of the lane had not signed me up
and i had an idea of the fact that a fifteen year let me out after five years.
I had to prolong the plan to get at the plantation. And i believe that now runs out and i'm going to have.
And you'll need me and i got it because he's a young man and the driver driving at wrecking made me happy.
And i didn't find that option.
And i'm a nice guy and i know that i believe you're right i mean that they could not put you up. I would probably be.
I mean i boarded. I got you some compensation. But we needn't. We had delayed. And it was a lot of work.
And i'm happy that the military have the final name to remember how many i think you are involved in that.
We have been and i get that. And i get the bananas. All right at the heart of me. Yeah. I get the magic.
Being engaged in a job. My dad needs.
And in the meantime we have to run somewhere on my network and date and that was the last time.
But of that we have to show you. I have now does have had already been shifting run to the store middle of july.
And i have been in these i'm going out of the brain that i hate.
But if i want to have this taken than alone
but the one i did not wish to go on the ground trying to prove that they can
and you know the very day that i live it might not matter and i took it down the road behind good.
And yeah i mean you know good and rebuild but it's not actually demolished you know.
Not in iraq that's what happened i took it away and rebuilt it. Thanks for bringing your own the original.
And i think it was it with not developed at all of its net net net net net net net none of the bananagrams would have
had it on the head to me and i don't have this. And that this with particularly nice bigger than.
United in the sun may have been at the bottom line on the inside and now.
Things which was right on me and i don't buy that many i behind it and.
The really nice about it after about three years i think of the nation and for me it happened to me and i'm alive
and i and eventually would need some named up.
That i missed and i will just go with what many thought from where i live for i will not go
or actually went to a fine school and i did a little down.
And when i was having a band i did we really never remain silent the same as without the foundation.
I know about a guy. And i did that or. I was with a friend then and i don't have a big you know.
What did you need from run to the next and to risk their time.
That you had never really had to write about it was trying to write right in front of the real. We've tried and tried.
Because i think i might have had a few months.
From a man of that that we had tried
and then that's where we found it ever very high because it was just not a lot of people still didn't have a will to
climb any really tenuous doors you telling me tonight along with his from nineteen year in and i think it was right
and i went and he came from. And it was from you go on. And if that g.
Got on with it we put a half up and i live with the love and love that about you now elaine.
That we have maintained and that we would have left to build to have fun.
But he said now he'd love us to know that they were banging out of there with nothing else we could do
and that we put it up here in the meantime we're living in a tame kind of a time out of the time we started with the
nineteenth. Of the good nature and he did it without a grain and with an answer and i started.
You did not commit a felony. And even a little she was reading about how fat. I got and downy. I needed it. We painted.
Kind of the night. Without you. But when i don't. And i have been have kind of man.
Red he runs with red meat and we have got a little bit of the rain. But then it was in the lane behind.
And i can remember the day that he thought i would run the drive the horses and in the little bit of the hill
and know what was the first game i have been used. Maybe right or wrong.
And i was the one that had to drive them in on the beginning not letting on a five dollar to tell you of that i had a
high temperature. And i didn't have a lot of the doesn't have the matter. In the moment. And now.
I can be just that we could run and we're going to do it.
If there are we haven't had this one made me and i think that you never know
when it's going to run you never know what the weather's going to do and of the back button of derived very little and.
And a firm grasp of it and. The lean and proper in the ground.
And i've done so here every now and then that he has you know
and i think you had it in you know yes i know i mean right he have a plan. And i drove the federal republic on the run.
Thank you and have said. It's been a happy one. We haven't and we got the bananas planted.
And that would have been about six months. Not just a good man idea that we have planned.
But we have to have very mixed up plans and that is that we haven't seen any..
You know anything about it for a long length of the i.g. That we get our plans from the north of we would know.
You would like to have a from anonymous.
But respect they were not in that in the grove i've been on the run you some of that equipment a lot of damage to them
and. It was early afternoon and there were a lot of again. With me having to run with counting down.
And with your band down towards the river and you could.
So you had rising and the river found i've been a fan of it it with an awful lot and to have you know.
The rounding we're running headlong. I mean down. You know.
Equivalent of you out of the ground you couldn't get any of the native revival. Bring it back.
Just to win the war and then we went inside. And we thought i would have a cup of coffee but only about three o'clock.
As we would making this coffee.
We have this time in the back of the house and it was a home with the fact that we went through there.
Where that man was in the back and we stood around a landslide have you know that he will
but i'm going to get i thought of something that they feel that we're going to be going to do.
And then you said we got me dying here and he said we have to get out of here i stand out of the hat.
And he got the utility and we had a five and utility. And he got it out and put it on the right.
I mean i've got a few things in the bag and a paper hang that he and me take that up into the. You know.
And just don't leave us alone the rant about the biggest landslide going down in iraq just go ahead.
And i just read on it and i've never seen it in the media. In the long run even thinking. And running.
Kind of a run of the. Random have just come out right in front of me and a half eventually settled.
I didn't get right on the ground because we had a few. Already gone. Rather than the night.
I was getting down to the ground. But. What have they not paying up when i don't have enough to be on into the night.
And i know we got out and let me just but i would not be looking fine thing.
Just me and i look back and i still might have but i really love them that would have been sitting you know not
but it rained in the rain we were invited to a number of life threatening i didn't know anything i write. Going back.
And we started making an ip next morning so i planned was out of that he finished and the sun was shining.
And with that map
and we went to the end of that we showed how the founder of the world for which i'm getting out of i think before would
have been actually settled.
Right down seventy five to me i mean damaging side with a few bits rather than have them out of the one man.
And i have them out without a problem on the baby. Making. Retro.
Means that anyone trying to look into a man will not reject kind again with the idea of storing it in.
And he knew somebody had these to him and from the mean man. And you have done this before.
And this time that you store bought. And i think you know. I think that. You know the real.
Sort of thing to do but i have learned that i'm not really good.
A lot of it in the heat and runs a guy not remembered when we don't have a clue we were living in a tank.
And i threw him but i've learned getting out and trying to lure me a handful of the five
and a frost on the way on the slide out in the out. Because i had to quit. And i mean it had to be a style that.
And we set it up and i took the tank up.
But after all it's running right you know for the one time that we had never worked on her and used to go out with.
You know little creek road and then a fire right we put on a little bit. In this creek a little behind it in the house.
And i lot left waiting with a lot of this time with some of the many seen.
And a bit of family wood on the stimulus left and.
I looked for them and then in the back and we just the right to live right.
And it was nigh by routine i'd died that night anyway you couldn't get a life but you get help
and you would have to borrow it. And i thought about this i mean we have one five gallon tank. And a tank.
Have to last you for him a thing. So that when it got down to the night. We used to grover the last time.
With the delighted when it was a night out about an assignment the roof.
Which would be about three feet and right and used for rushing to the bathroom if you know. It had to mean.
Just for the peach and then have time to have to make out and run somewhere else. So i will have a few crisis. Of the.
Row. Jean-guy. It wasn't anything to write a little. When you have a line.
And i just don't think it's going to break
when i did write what i thought it was in such a position that we couldn't get it in the hands. But. Just went on and.
We went on and on and we planted them right now. I know. And i've gotten out. And we had to go ahead.
And i had the run up tonight it was too loud. And it got arrested for the love that it was nothing.
And then eventually the bananas.
Need to get better would be ending and it was my job to tie the knot in with the slide.
And we have to agree need to hold the planning's and run with your little rock.
I love to write about my husband for me
but to give the other one lesson would be to make the thought that he would rather than me with this that he was
writing and putting them on the road.
And i was writing something that for people who might have never wanted to grow up
and it ran through the been out of the flat going to get into the band stuff. Then of the shit.
I've written down near the front of the sheet. And i move the nominee. And it and you have to try to get it behind.
Right. I mean we have to go on but i'm glad i'm writing it and i don't.
And you know we had not heard of you know we had in the main time of growth when we've been a good guy
and we're expanding the half a night and a bubble of thanks tonight and i give you the money we handed me.
In between the bananas which everybody needs actually been the man is right it's right for the brand with already got
about it.
That we've named names but you get a little bit of money to carry around many of the time and maybe that's
when you have to buy right. And time money and i need now i know. And then of course when you buy right.
You have to back it up and run with it.